make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing our coverage
of Swan and in this video we're getting
into the origin of Angela now
technically speaking this doesn't happen
in this order in terms of continuity it
actually comes later on as part of the
curse of spawned storylines and the
curses spawn was basically a kind of
sight along series you know what we
mentioned in the last video was it was a
companion series they gave us like the
origins and stories of various
characters who were out there I would
say Angela is probably the most popular
of the supporting characters and a lot
of you guys who were unfamiliar with
spawn but are familiar with Marvel are
probably looking at this and saying I
thought Angela was a Marvel character
and she is now but it wasn't always that
way
that was spawn issues 9 10 and 11 Todd
McFarlane had basically contracted out
to Neil Diamond Dave sim and Frank
Miller and then actually had Alan Moore
write a story as well but basically they
were contracted out to write these one
shots before the spawn comic and the
reason why was really just to draw names
you know to draw attention
you know readership to it the sense that
image was already really popular at the
time and so was spawn spawn was huge but
in order to kind of keep that momentum
going it behooves Todd McFarlane to like
have an issue that has has like a big
name and Frank Miller had been a big
name for quite some time especially
right after his run on daredevil and
going into the Dark Knight Returns right
I mean the guy who like set the world on
fire with his daredevil run so it only
made sense it after the Dark Knight
Returns he was like a huge name right so
to have him attached to a spawn story
would draw a lot of eyes to it the thing
that makes us interesting is that Neil
Gaiman had introduced a couple of
different characters in addition to
Angela in issue number 9 right in in and
spawn issue numb or not but this was
kind of a point of contestation between
Todd McFarlane and Neil Gaiman insofar
as when image are in terms of their
policy it was the idea that if you
create a character you own the character
right that was their big beef with
Marvel Y there was the idea that like if
you create a character for Marvel then
like it belongs to Marvel now whereas if
you create a character an image it's
wholly yours you know whether you can
market it or not it's totally up to you
but they're just a publishing house
right it's your work it's your thing you
don't have to worry about selling off
the rights to anybody
Angela proved to be exceedingly popular
and so what this did is it led to a
legal dispute that was settled in 2002
and then finalized in 2012 and the way
this played out is that with Angela
being as popular as she was and the Neil
Diamond coming along with the idea that
I created the character even though
technically according to McFarlane he
argued that Neil Gaiman was basically
contracted to create a character or to
write a story meaning that the character
that was created Angela
owned by McFarland and not by a Neil
Diamond because it was created for Todd
McFarlane's title this ended up kind of
a pretty lengthy lawsuit the span knew a
pretty good amount of time in 2002 it
was kind of settled in the sense that
like they both co-owned the characters
that Neil Gaiman had created and then in
2012 Neil Gaiman got total ownership of
Angela this coincided with the desire of
Joe Quesada in them and Marvel to bring
Angela over to Marvel Comics probably
one of the most squandered opportunities
in the history of comic books the result
was that in 2013 Angela was basically
purchased directly by Marvel from Neil
Diamond and then brought in through age
of Ultron and they never did anything
with her right they made her like Angela
queen of Hell and then just wasted her
after that she was online I think most
recently she was on like as guardians of
the galaxy Angela needs her own solo
book she's interesting enough but she's
super if she's super cool but this is
the original origin for Angela in the
spawn comics right so the way this plays
out we're kind of yanking this out of an
existing story there is kind of a story
that's going on at the moment it's not
really relevant to what's going on with
her character it will be later on those
are guys who recognize the face of this
guy the man with the glasses please do
not spoil anything please do not tell
people I know it's a pointless endeavor
to ask that but please don't tell people
but but in any event basically this
picks up with a woman essentially just
like fleeing for her life with her baby
in the era of like proto man a hundred
thousand years ago now that number one
hundred thousand is pretty important but
basically it's a hundred thousand years
ago that this all takes place and this
one is basically fleeing for your life
from bandits and all kinds of crazy guys
and then in the midst of it all she kind
of sees this face looking at her from a
rock and then it's sort of overcome with
like this rage right and ultimately ends
up killing all these guys well then
following that she takes the baby ends
up putting it in a tree when you have
these wild cats more or less let's start
like consuming the corpses of these men
but fearing for the death of her and her
child she puts a baby in a tree and then
ultimately ends up just kind of
sacrificing your life to ensure her
baby's survival right in the moments
when this happens a kind of angel comes
down a Seraphim comes down and then
basically rescues the baby right by this
woman sacrifices her life to save the
life of her child following that you
jump directly to Egypt and what you have
is this woman who's basically being made
to work with slave labor and where you
end up having you know the last of her
sons who's basically killed his muscles
give out he hasn't really eaten or drank
anything and he's crushed by one of the
rocks she really kind of goes to grief
to him and then in turn is whipped to
the point where she almost dies
that they take her they they whip her
even further then they string her up and
leave her to die and again you know
really she really just kind of greets
her son you know as an angel that comes
down and tells her the life you're gonna
get after this this kind of life ever
after is infinitely better than anything
you're experiencing here but yet again
this spectre of death shows up and so
from there you jump to a young girl and
we're not really given a timeframe were
just told it's during the era after
slavery if I were a betting man I would
say this is probably during the Rosewood
massacre if you guys are familiar with
that you should look it up the Rosewood
massacre is a really important moment in
American southern and black history but
basically this young girl is kind of
fleeing for her life after her parents
were killed right in what's called the
force of dead bodies and so far as there
was a point whereby all these bodies
were strung up from trees and literally
when you went through there it was just
all these bodies hanging and the result
is that she again sees the spectre of
this guy and just kind of runs as fast
as she can to get away as best she can
as she ends up stumbling across the
young boy that she spent time with named
Jeremiah who of course was hung as well
but if she's fleeing she ends up
tripping over this branch and is up
going you know falling down this
hillside and into the water where she
doesn't really have the ability to swim
and begins to drown and then pleas for
help one of the Klansmen Caesar and then
shoots her and that's the end of her but
she's greeted by the angelic appearances
more or less of her mother and her
father who really does kind of whisk her
away to heaven and so following that you
travel to Auschwitz and I hope you guys
are kind of noticing a pattern here is
this pattern of basically people dying
but experiencing the process of
traveling to heaven for this one
particular woman her children are also
being sent to the gas chambers
and so as a result of this actually
basically you know plead to their
children to just run as best they can
and the reality is they were probably
going to die but in a situation as
desperate as that to just flee and have
the chance of escaping it's better than
just like going to the gas chambers
right it is you know any chance for hope
any chance for survival for her children
is better than none at all and so of
course with their children basically
being mowed down she in turn is is taken
back into the line and she kind of
perceives forward accordingly and then
you know ultimately ends up perishing in
the gas chambers but that's how this
process is over and over and over again
and so the final person that we get is
basically this very very old woman who's
essentially dying of cancer and her life
is for the most part completely gone to
pieces her husband as it has essentially
abandoned her he was struggling with
alcoholism the youngest of her sons
basically died of AIDS for two daughters
are living out in the world somewhere
and don't care how she's doing her
his son has basically been consumed by
alcoholism as well there's really
nothing left in her life it's just her
with nothing to really live for and so
seeing this spectre of death
she basically ends ups you know kind of
giving up and ultimately ends up
perishing but what matters here is that
these five individuals who basically
died by tragic means but who were
greeted with life everlasting
following their death all sort of
coalesce and come together in the form
of Angela now the question is why and
this comes by way of a woman named
Katherine what we end up doing is
traveling to a place called Elysium and
when when Angela is more or less born or
when she's kind of coalesced into the
beam that she is now from these five
spirits that following this birthing
process
Katherine begins to sort of give her a
tour of this area showing her what's
around here showing her what Elysium is
and basically says that we are
essentially angels is more or less what
she says right we're angels were more or
less soldiers and we are kind of the
antithesis of the hell spawns
that mal Bhoja he has this massive army
of individuals that he's creating and he
has these hell spawns that get created
every so often they're designed to kind
of lead his army of the dead by whatever
manner and whatever means our job is to
kill them and to ensure that leadership
role is never undertaken and what they
have is what's called a Hall of trophies
basically all the different hell spawns
over the however long this wars been
going on that they've killed right
successfully managed to eliminate and
it's kind of a cool thing right because
what this does is it expands on the
notion of good and evil right because
when you kind of look at the spawn
mythos it's just like Al Simmons running
around killing people who do bad things
and that's it but this really sort of
expanded the landscape in a huge way now
by the time this curse of the hell spawn
story had come out the landscape had
been expanded by a pretty good chunk but
I just didn't really involve Angela it
did but you didn't really know where
character her origin or anything along
those lines but what happens as Angela's
basically taken to this door that stands
a thousand feet tall and when she enters
she encounters God and what God does is
basically start taking her through and
essentially saying you know when Angela
asked like is this heaven God says no
it's just kind of a place where I walk
around and just do my own thing and
gather my thoughts and so on but what
God does is basically say you were
created by these five individual souls
who would sacrifice their lives for the
people that they love and what this
meant was that you are by definition of
being composed of goodness and that's
why you exist the way you do because if
you were being composed of evil you
would succumb to the power of mal Bhoja
now in in the spawn universe when it
comes to like good guys and bad guys
it gets pretty blurry
so she's a good guy insofar as like good
and evil are defined in the spawn
universe but essentially it's this
notion of your job is to go out there
and to basically fight off these various
members of the hell spawn right but you
can never stop you can never give ground
that evil is a force that's always
encroaching it's always trying to drag
you down it's always trying to convince
you that you can't win but you have to
keep on fighting because if you don't
then yes you will lose right so it is a
constant struggle and it is a constant
battle but it's one of these these
battles that more or less has to always
be fun and so it's kind of a cool moment
because following this what you end up
getting is Angela basically engaging in
this kind of combat of sorts with
Catholic how to train her get her
prepared for what it means to be a
soldier of heaven and you get this kind
of cool moment because what they end up
doing you know in kind of this thing you
know Catherine says well I want to show
you something before we eat before we
you know depart before you're officially
inducted into our guild for lack of a
better word you know and she says this
is a very very old hell squad right this
guy is exceedingly powerful and Angela's
kind of taken aback she's kind of
surprised by how capable and how massive
this force is and she's kinda like you
know who in the world took this guy out
was it you and the response of Catherine
was no it was you a hundred thousand
years ago right like a long long time
ago and where Angela looks at this and
says that doesn't make any sense I've
just now been created how could this
have possibly been done so long ago
that's where we sort of get this
explanation of how it is that Angela can
be 100 thousand years old yet have been
created after the events of like World
War two that when it comes to Elysium it
spreads all across time and space you
can go to any point in time in any space
you want to within the universe from
Elysium and so the idea is following her
creation she sent a hundred thousand
years ago to go on a mission to kind of
just eliminate people to basically take
out these various hell spawns that are
out there and so following this process
of basically being inducted into the
angelic soldiers these angelic warriors
what Angela is given are two things the
first are the angelic ribbons and the
second is the dimensional lance the
angelic ribbon is similar to like spawns
k7 Letha which is the suit that he wears
which grants them the ability to kind of
extend us throughout to you know create
weapons or stabbing objects and
different things like that but it's an
extension of himself that kind of helps
to bolster his abilities in combat I can
just outright like heal him and even
operate of its own accord
right his father's knocked unconscious
it'll continue to protect him things
along those one's the ribbons aren't
really exactly like the k7 Letha they do
offer some measure of support in this
sense they can keep Angela warm or they
can kind of be in
extension of combat they're not
indestructible but they can't help her
in combat but the dimensional lance is
really the important object the one
thing that really allows Angela to
defeat hell spawns now the form and
function of the dimensional lance is
actually explained in the first
appearance of Angela in spawn issue
number nine and we'll cover it here but
we'll also cover it again once we get to
that but Angela really kind of run over
as the various weapons that are
available to warriors of heaven who
tracked down these hell spawns and face
off against them and because of the fact
that things like the k7 Leatha are so
capable that what they end up having to
do is use the the dimensional lance in
order to get into close proximity to a
hell spawn and then send it away from
this dimension leaving only its carapace
behind or it's suit basically the case
of and Letha behind which can actually
be captured by Angela and in turn you
know what's is terminated use it as a
trophy and take it back and that's how
things have always kind of been done
right as how things are always sort of
been handled when it comes to the
various warriors of heaven the funny
thing is that when Angela encounters
spawn for the first time things are
gonna go radically different well they
will but they won't they will not go in
the way that Angela expects but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end this is the origin of
Angela she's officially inducted into
the ranks of the warriors of Heaven and
goes forward to become a killer of hell
spawns until she meets Al Simmons and
then everything changes but we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you guys
are new here to comments explain and
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
Bruce I want to say thank you to all of
the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explain I want
to give a shout out to Henry young -
Elias G David J s Jacob H Ben John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M Steven Z
sloth-like Lou David see John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time Adam Cajun gnosis 916 I want to say
thank you to all of you all this list is
growing all the time leave it to the
patreon
[Music]
[Music]
you